hi everyone
this is professor m does science and
today i want to discuss the
symmetrization
postulate in another one of our videos
on rigorous quantum mechanics we found
on the video on exchange degeneracy
that we can build an infinite number of
apparently equivalent states
to describe a system of identical
quantum particles
however we also found that applying the
usual rules of quantum mechanics
leads to different predictions depending
on which of these states we choose
that is clearly a big problem today
we'll resolve this by introducing a new
postulate
the symmetrization postulate this will
allow us to recover
the predictive power of quantum
mechanics when we have multiple
identical particles on top of that we
will introduce ideas like bosons and
fermions
that you'll probably have heard about so
let's go
before we introduce the symmetrization
postulate let's start with a refresher
about two prerequisite topics
let's start with symmetric and
antisymmetric states
if we act with any permutation p alpha
on a state
psi plus and we get psi plus back then
psi plus belongs to a subspace called
v plus and we say that it is a totally
symmetric state
similarly if we act with any permutation
p alpha on a state psi
minus and we get back eta alpha psi
minus then this state belongs to a
subspace called v minus
and we say that it is a totally
anti-symmetric state
in this expression eta is plus 1 for
even permutations and -1 for odd
permutations
we also know that we can construct this
totally symmetric or anti-symmetric
state by applying an appropriate
projection operator on an arbitrary
state
the first projector is s plus and it is
defined by 1
over n factorial multiplying the sum
over all n factorial permutations p
alpha s plus projects any state
psi onto a totally symmetric state and
we call it the symmetrizer
the second projector is s minus and it
is defined by 1 over
n factorial multiplying the sum over eta
alpha p
alpha running over all permutations
again
s minus projects any state psi onto a
totally anti-symmetric state
and we call it the antisymmetrizer
the second prerequisites topic is
exchange degeneracy
consider cat psi belonging to the state
space v
of an n-particle system of identical
particles which as usually is given by
the tensor product of a single particle
state spaces
also consider the n-factorial ket's p
alpha psi given by all possible
permutations of the n particles
the set of cats span a subspace of v
called veep psi
and any state in veep psi is a state
that mathematically describes the same
situation
this is what we call exchange degeneracy
however in the video on exchange
degeneracy we found a big problem
any state in vip psi mathematically
describes our system
but when we use them to make physical
predictions using the usual rules of
quantum mechanics we get different
answers depending on which state we
choose clearly this is a problem for any
physical theory so exchange degeneracy
needs to be removed
which state describes the physical
system
as we will see the symmetrization
postulate allows us to solve this
problem
if you want a more in-depth discussion
about these topics check the
corresponding videos in the description
otherwise let's go on to the
symmetrization postulate
the symmetrization postulate says that
for a system of identical particles
the only cats of its state space that
can describe physical states are the
following
either totally symmetric cats with
respect to permutations of identical
particles
and the particles that obey these are
called bosons
or the only other option is totally
anti-symmetric cats with respect to
permutations of identical particles
and the particles that obey these are
called fermions
let's stop here for a moment does it
make sense that systems of identical
particles are described by these two
types of state
we know that exchanging two identical
particles doesn't affect the physics of
the problem
this is actually precisely what these
states do
bosons are particles described by
totalismatic states
through which exchanging any two
particles leads to exactly the same
state
fermions are particles described by
totally anti-symmetric states
for which exchanging any two particles
leads to the same state
with an extra minus sign this means that
these states capture the necessary
property of systems of identical
particles that exchanging anita
particles should not affect the physics
remember that for n distinguishable
particles the state space v
is the tensor product space of single
particle state spaces v1
v2 all the way to vn what the
symmetrization postulate tells us is
that for a system of n
identical particles then the combined
state space is no longer v
instead it is one of two subspaces of v
either v
plus spanned by the total symmetric
states or v minus
spanned by the totally anti-symmetric
states
the symmetrization postulate implies
that all particles in nature can be
classified into two groups
bosons and fermions the question that
emerges is how do we know if a given
particle is a boson or a fermion
in introductory quantum mechanics we
will use an empirical rule derived from
experiment to answer this question
one particles with integer spin are
bosons
examples include elementary particles
like photons but also non-elementary
particles like mesons
made of two quarks or helium-4 an
isotope of helium made of two protons
two neutrons and two electrons
two particles with half integer spin are
fermions
examples include elementary particles
like electrons or muons
and non-elementary particles like
protons or neutrons
each made of three quarks or helium-3
another isotope of helium made of two
protons
one neutron and two electrons
for elementary particles their spin is
an intrinsic defining property
for non-elementary particles we need to
combine the spins of the elementary
particles making them up in the usual
manner to decide what the total spin
is for example as quarks are spin
one-half particles
then a meson that has two quarks will
have integer spin
so it is a boson a proton that has three
quarks will have half integer spin
so it is a fermion as i said earlier
in introductory quantum mechanics the
relation between spin and the bosonic or
permeating nature of particles is taken
as an empirical rule
in quantum field theory which roughly
speaking is the extension of quantum
mechanics to include the effects of
special relativity
there is something called the spin
statistics theorem in which this
empirical rule is derived
rather than assumed however the spin
statistic theorem itself is in turn
based on more general hypotheses that
also have to be taken as given without
proof
the reason why we had to introduce the
symmetrization postulate is because of
exchange degeneracy
so what we have to show now is that the
symmetrization postulate allows us to
remove exchange degeneracy
and recover the ability of quantum
theory to make predictions about nature
when we have a system of identical
particles
consider a cat psi in the tensor product
space v
then the cat's p alpha psi span the
subspace
vpsi and any ket that lives in this
subspace is a mathematically valid ket
and this is precisely what we call
exchange degeneracy
on the other hand the symmetrization
postulate tells us that the physically
allowed cats
live in either v plus or bosons or v
minus for fermions
this means that what we have to show is
that of all possible kets in veep psi
there is only one that also lives in v
plus or v minus
the proof in fact is very simple and
relies on these results up here that we
obtained in the video on symmetric and
anti-semantic states
the first shows that the symmetrizer s
plus commutes with all permutations
and that both terms are equal to s plus
and the second
that the anti-symmetrizer s minus
commutes with all permutations
and both terms are equal to eta alpha s
minus
let's now consider a ket psi that lives
in veep psi
to follow the symmetrization postulate
we must symmetrize this state
and we do this by applying the
symmetrizer s plus on psi
which gives the state that lives in the
plus
now let's consider the permutation p
alpha psi which also lives in website
following the symmetrization postulate
again we must symmetrize this state
and to do this we again apply the
symmetrizer s plus on p alpha psi
we can now use the result up here that s
plus p alpha equals s plus to get this
equal to s plus psi and this is again a
state that belongs to v
plus so what does this mean
starting from two different cats psi and
p alpha psi
both in vip psi when we symmetrize them
we end up with the same state
here and here in v plus
so why is this result so important of
all the possible permutations of a
ketpside that live in vpsi
and are responsible for exchange
degeneracy when we apply the
symmetrization postulate and project
this stage onto v
plus we get the exact same state
this means there are no longer multiple
states but a single one
so the symmetrization postulate removes
exchange degeneracy
we can of course make a similar argument
if we apply the anti-symmetrizer on a
permutation of
psi remember that s minus p alpha equals
eta alpha
s minus so we get this
we again find that any permutation of a
ket psi
anti-symmetrizes to the same state in
this case up to a minus sign
this means that we also remove exchange
degeneracy for fermions using the
symmetrization postulate
overall of all the permutations of a
state that we have in state space v
we have a single state in the symmetric
analysis spaces v plus and v minus
we can therefore say that d-cat that
describes a physical state for bosons
is s plus psi and for fermions
it is s minus psi
now that we have seen how the
symmetrization postulate allows us to
remove
exchange degeneracy the only thing that
is left to discuss is how we go about
constructing
from all the mathematically allowed cats
the physical cat for our system of
identical particles
the procedure is pretty straightforward
and in the rest of the video we'll show
a few examples of how to build
multi-particle states
in quantum mechanics let's start with
the simplest possible example
a two particle system let's imagine that
one particle is found in a single
particle state phi
and the other in the single particle
state chi
to construct the physical states the
first step is to arbitrarily associate
each of the two cats with a particle
say ket5 with one and ketkai with two
then we build the state psi as a denser
product of phi
1 and chi 2 which belongs to the tensor
product state space v
remember that we can use a simple
notation that emits the tensor product
symbol like this
the second step is to project this state
onto the v plus and v minus subspaces
if we apply the symmetrizer to psi we
can then explicitly write out the two
permutations p12
and p21 acting on psi which we also
write out
and using the action of the permutation
operators we get this
this state corresponds to bosons
if we apply the anti-symmetrizer to psi
we can then again write out the relevant
terms here
and we get this
the state has an additional negative
sign and corresponds to fermions
the third and final step is to normalize
the state
we need to distinguish two situations
the first
corresponds to phi different from chi in
this case the normalized states are
simply 1 over square root of 2
phi 1 chi 2 plus minus chi 1 phi 2.
the second case corresponds to phi equal
to chi
for bosons we have this
and combining the two terms reduces to
the original state that is already
normalized in this case the original
state was already symmetric with respect
to particle exchange
for fermions we get this
but now combining this to state actually
gives zero
what does this mean there is no ket in v
minus that can describe this physical
state
this result is a very striking feature
of the quantum theory of identical
particles and is called the pauli
exclusion principle two identical
fermions cannot be in the same single
particle state
i bet you have all heard before about
the pauli exclusion principle which is
an extremely famous result
it features in many areas for example in
atomic structure where it tells us how
to arrange electrons in atoms
and gives rise to the structure of the
periodic table of elements
let's now look at a three particle
system
the single particle states are phi chi
and omega step one is to build psi
like this again randomly associating
each state with a particle
in step two for bosons we apply the
symmetrizer on psi
explicitly writing the symmetrizer gives
this
and we can then expand the sum with all
six permutations of three elements
and we get six terms phi chi omega
omega phi chi chi omega phi
phi omega chi chi phi omega
omega chi phi in step 3 let's consider
various situations
first if phi chi and omega are all
different
then the normalized state is simply
given by the same six terms we just got
in step two
but now the pre-factor is one over
square root of six
second if phi and chi are equal but
different to omega
then we get this normalized state in
which we only have three different terms
and the normalization pre-factor is one
over square root of three
and third if all single particle states
are equal
then the state is simply this one term
what about fermions now in step 2 we
need to apply the antisymmetrizer on psi
which explicitly is given by this
and if we expand it out it looks very
similar to the one for bosons
we also get six terms the first three
are the same
phi chi omega omega phi chi
chi omega phi but the last three terms
have a negative sign
minus phi omega chi minus chi phi omega
and minus omega chi phi this negative
sign
arises because the terms correspond to
odd permutations
for fermions if any two of phi chi or
omega are equal
then this expression will be zero and
the normalization is therefore always
the same for fermions
all we have to do is to replace the term
here by the square root
to obtain a normalized state this
vanishing of the fermionic state if any
two single particle states are the same
is again
the parallel exclusion principle
these ideas are all easily generalized
to an arbitrary and particle system
whose single particle states are labeled
by phi 1 phi 2
and so on first we build the ket psi
as the tensor product of the single
particle states where they are ordered
in an arbitrary fashion
second for bosons we apply the
symmetrizer on psi
and we obtain this
when this bosonic state is represented
in the position basis in terms of wave
functions this object is sometimes
called
the permanent for fermions
we apply the antisymmetrizer on psi
and we get this
when this fermionic state is represented
in the position basis in terms of wave
functions
the signs introduced by the eta alpha
obey the same rules as those introduced
by the calculation of a determinant
this means that we can then rewrite this
expression in terms of the determinant
of the single particle wave functions
and because such determinants appear
whenever we have a system of identical
fermions
they have a special name they are called
slater determinants
third always remember to normalize
today we have resolved a big problem
that exchanged the generacy post
in doing that we have seen that all
particles in nature
are either bosons described by totally
symmetric states
or fermions described by totally
antisymmetric states the simple
difference between bosons and fermions
has massive consequences for the
behavior of these two types of particles
some of which can even be observed
microscopically i'll give you two quick
examples
the symmetric states of bosons mean that
they can all collapse to the same
quantum state
to form something called the
bose-einstein condensate
also called the fifth state of matter
the pauli extrusion principle
the bait by fermions means that there is
an effective force
that can even counteract gravity this is
precisely the force that stabilizes
neutron stars and prevents a
gravitational collapse
if you liked the video or would like to
send me suggestions for future videos
please subscribe